after Donald Trump gave this interview
to Sean Hannity last night
a number of Republicans including even
on Fox news said this is not so good
this is not so good first example is
former Republican Congressman Jason
Chaffetz also a current Fox contributor
who says this was a very bad interview
Trump gave a bad interview uh Jason you
said overall you thought president Trump
did a very poor job in the interview why
I
thought a good job
um but I watched that and I thought
where is Donald Trump I I voted for
Donald Trump twice I have defended him
countless times I thought he was
horrific I think that was the worst
interview I've seen the president do he
was whining he was complaining
um he does that in every interview but
it was particularly bad the victim card
time and time again
um and then after that he complained
that you know somebody had endorsed was
now running against him and I I thought
he was absolutely horrific he's the
former president of the United States
act like it he didn't in that interview
wow wow and then even Brian Kilmeade
when he weighed in about it one of the
hosts of fox and friends this morning
saying you know he's kind of punching
down and he really should not do that
and as far as kill Mead goes this is
about as strong of a criticism of trump
as you will ever hear
and George Bush 41 wanted to tear each
other's eyes out John McCain and George
W bush never really got over the
personal animosity as they locked horns
uh you could say that Barack Obama and
Hillary Clinton it got extremely
personal and they've never been closed
since even though they worked together
for a short period of time so this is
not unusual but a usual attack on Ron
DeSantis would be I respect him from
what he's done but I'm the one with
International experience I'm the one
that did the Abraham Accords I'm the one
that made NATO pay up to 10 I'm the one
that made sure that Ukraine wasn't
invaded I'm the one I mean a lot of
those things are lies but okay gave them
weapons to defend themselves not MREs so
you point energy yeah it seems to me the
tactic more traditionally would be yeah
around at 44 years old he's done a lot
but look at what I have done in four
years and these are the same players I
like to go back and finish the job and
he's been very nice thank you Haley I
think he's been deferential to Mike
Pompeo uh and Tim Scott I can't imagine
saying something bad about Tim Scott AI
but with uh Ron DeSantis he sees a
threat but I think that his best offense
as the front run would be don't punch
down don't punch down says Brian kill me
so listen this is the start this is the
start
and we will see if it continues of some
Republicans saying this entire obsession
with the santis thing the attacks the
criticisms the punching down as Brian
Kilmeade calls it the whining is Jason
Chaffetz called it this isn't good for
Trump now I think the Counterpoint to
this is that Trump is so far ahead and
despite allegedly facing an imminent
arrest he is polling more and more
strongly against DeSantis who meanwhile
is on a book tour and getting tons of
favorable press and softball interviews
and desantis's polling is decreasing so
while I agree with the criticism I don't
know that Republicans care about Trump
whining and punching down and all of the
things that he's doing and also it
doesn't seem like they are flocking to
DeSantis in the way that at one moment
it was predicted that they would the
next step is is Ron DeSantis going to
run or isn't he
if anything the recent polling over the
last 10 to 14 days declining might get
to sandus to reconsider but we're going
to watch it some Republicans not at all
pleased with this latest disoriented
interview on Fox news by Trump
if you're like me and you love The
Nostalgia of enjoying a bowl of cereal
sometimes as an adult check out our
sponsor magic spoon magic spoon is the
breakfast cereal with the crunchy sweet
goodness you love but with zero grams of
sugar more protein and only four to five
net carbs so it's perfect if you're
doing low carb if you're doing keto if
you're like me and you just don't want
to eat a bunch of sugar magic spoon has
delicious flavors to choose from cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter Honey Nut
cinnamon roll birthday cake my favorite
is maple waffle and right now they have
limited edition spring flavors
strawberry milkshake and peaches and
cream sometimes you just feel like
sitting down with a bowl of cereal when
the mood strikes go for something with
plenty of protein
without all the sugar if you don't love
magic spoon as much as I do and our team
does magic spoon will refund all of your
money no questions asked go to
magicspoon.com Pacman create a custom
bundle use the code Pacman for five
dollars off the link is down below